this morning on the dish a fourth of
july barbecue courtesy of oakland
california's self-taught pit master matt
horn the 34 year old has gained
legendary status in the east bay named
one of food and wine's best new chefs
last year while his restaurant horn
barbecue earned a michelin bib gourmand
award and was a james beard finalist for
best new restaurant horn's journey from
novice to award-winning chef is
chronicled in his new cookbook named for
his restaurant and meant to serve as
both barbecue guide and inspiration to
at home cooks who've dreamed of more
it's the barbecue that draws customers
in droves we just hit our brakes
furiously when we smelled the goodness
coming out of this place horn barbecue
in oakland this one right here since
opening about two years ago it's been
known for both its snaking lines
gotcha and mouth-watering meats and
sides i'm going pulled pork i might get
the pit beans maybe some mac dubbed west
coast style barbecue its roots are in
texas and the south the best barbecue
i've had outside of texas
well this is like our primary
cut of meat this is what everybody lines
up for so this is the brisket this is
the brisket
for pit master matt horn barbecue isn't
just the finished product it's a journey
the smoke will come and it'll go right
over it from prepping and seasoning the
meat
to stoking the fire that brings it to
light
barbecue is more than just throwing logs
in there and that sort of thing it's
very careful fire management you know
you have to maintain that temperature
and how long does it smoke for so we
usually smoke our briskets for about 14
to 16 hours it's definitely a commitment
you know it's a labor of love
and appreciation horn learned along the
way i mean in the beginning i'm just
like okay i want to hurry up and finish
the cook and you find yourself
popping the lid and looking you know
what i did was i started to realize that
throughout the cooking journey you want
to trust the smoker to do what it was
built to do be one with the fire
be in the moment be present and that's
what i've learned to do
this is the finished product right here
patience is now a virtue for horn but
not for me matt i'm drooling can i
please taste absolutely
there you go enjoy
it melts in your mouth
oh my god
i'm gonna be very unladylike i have to
taste this
jalapeno cheddar right yep jalapeno
cheddar i got a full spread to sample in
a backyard barbecue starting with
homemade jalapeno cheddar sausage links
i used to always see my grandfather
eating the hot links he would take it
right off the grill and he would grab a
piece of white bread and just do it he
would just do it that way that nod to
family in everything from the smoked
chicken pulled pork and ribs to the pit
beans collard greens and mac and cheese
grandma he says gets credit for the
dessert you gotta have banana pudding oh
this is delicious
like the barbecue he serves horn's
journey in it can be traced to childhood
when his grandfather was the pit master
whether it was a wedding a funeral a
birthday or just a family gathering you
know you'd always smell the smoke the
fire would be lit and there would always
be a barbecue in his early 20s cooking
became horn's escape from his day job he
soon realized it was even more not only
did it give me purpose but i felt
fulfilled with what i was doing in my
life finally for the first time in my
life once i decided that i want to start
cooking you know it was a clear choice
that i wanted to do barbecue because
that was the thing that brought us
together as a family to hone the craft
of barbecue horn turned to where it all
began i would drive down from los
angeles every weekend to my
grandmother's backyard and i take a
notepad and i grab a few cuts of meat
and i will fire the pit up and i would
take extremely extensive notes your
grandfather's pit oh yeah and that was
the only place where i can really
barbecue after a few months in the
backyard with family taste testers horn
headed to a farmer's market to sell his
barbecue i had about a little under a
couple hundred bucks
and i bought as much meat as i can with
that and i just literally believed in
like hey if i don't cut corners and i
contribute love and commit myself to
this someone will connect with it and we
went through the farmer's market for a
year
and we struggle i even begin to question
am i doing the right thing what changed
your mind i took a few days off and i
didn't cook at all and i found myself
laying in bed
thinking about the smoke the fire
all these beautiful elements that make
barbecue what it is and i'm just like
you know what i have to continue to push
forward with this
that feeling was validated when horn
launched his very first pop-up barbecue
i sat in my truck and i was really
emotional why because i was grateful
that they even came to even to enjoy the
food and then the next papa we had is 50
people there
and then the next one you know over 100
but little did i know that it would turn
into what it turned into it was one of
the largest pop-ups
in the country and
hundreds of people waiting hours i mean
i mean i can't even yeah and they would
set up their lawn chairs they would set
up tents people do that for sporting
events you've gotten that sword
right i know and it was a beautiful
thing and i always made it an effort to
go out and shake everyone's hand and
thank everybody for coming no matter how
long it took
when his restaurant became a reality in
the same area where his pop-ups became
legendary horn made sure to include
reminders of his journey
including his smoker lucille there from
the start her name a tribute to the
iconic bb king song
lucille
i would find myself in all these
different places
farms
at breweries and parking lots alleys
whatever
sitting there by the fire i'd have
lucille by b.b king playing every single
time there was always something about
that song that always made me
i don't know it always connected me back
to the purpose of why i do what i do
with barbecue
he says it's his way of giving love
something he's getting back in return
this thought that i had
to commit myself to cooking
it's brought me to where i am here now
you know and i wish both of my
grandfathers was here to just see like
hey you know what that thing that
brought our family together the thing
that we've all connected to
i've taken that and i'm sharing it with
my community and
we're getting the recognition for it and
we're grateful
and i have had some scent to share with
you couple things i want to mention that
farmer's market when he was working
there never made more than
250 dollars a day but persevered as he
talked about it's now actually horn
hospitality group they have cowbird also
in oakland which is a chicken place
i'm telling you you got a taste it's it
is absolutely appealing and such an
inspiring story of somebody seeing a
vision having a vision and really
sticking with it because it was his love
and his passion and it fulfilled him and
it tastes really really good right it's
delicious um
obviously we have the brisket i should
mention we have the jalapeno sausage
jalapeno cheddar sausage the ribs the
mac and cheese collard greens and cheers
cheers to that right